transforming the economy by generating
415 billion euros and creating thousands
of jobs that's what a fully functioning
digital single market could do for
Europe MEP s gave it their support at a
vote in Strasburg on Tuesday the economy
is becoming more and more digital we can
see how those digital barriers dividing
our member states are coming back we
have to create digital single market in
the European Union first things first
getting rid of barriers across the 28
member states to make sure that
consumers have greater access to goods
and services online if there are 28 sets
of for example consumer protection rules
then then companies just don't sell
cross borders but there's a big
difference when you sell to a market of
1 million or 5 million or to a market to
500 million another focal point or the
discussion in the chamber was
geo-blocking the practice that prevents
the user accessing information based on
their countrywide location the
Parliament calls for an end unjustified
geo-blocking this goes against the very
foundation of a single market so I don't
think there can be justified to your
blocking inside the digital single
market but what MEP sake is required is
to put the consumer first and for
innovation to be allowed to flourish so
far the digital single market is merely
a concept but expect the Commission to
put flesh on the bones of their proposal
later on in the year
Oh